on the screen as well
foreign
welcome councils to this meeting of
council this is a public meeting being
streamed live to YouTube and we are the
council's website the meeting is also
being recorded for the purpose of the
minutes
I have been advised that the live stream
is now up and running
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting over the
live stream we will adjourn until the
connection has been and re-established
can I ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present thank you
thank you chair so in the meeting room
today
we have uh counselors and Cliff Armitage
Parker Birkin
Kevin Boone Pat bone
cloth Cooper Cornwell Cube pit day Dale
Dayton Elliott Emmons Angelique Foster
Mark Foster for now go mizrini Paul
Hancock
also on Hill
Hutchinson Jones Kenyon Kerry Lewis
Liggett Lily
parking Pickering pots towel reader
renick Ridgeway row
rough shipment Stone Tate
backer Welton Whitehead windley and
Philip Wright and and prior to the
meeting all those members have been
checked in to confirm that they can see
and hear during this meeting
um May I remind members to abide by the
etiquette that's been provided for you
for use at Council meetings
if you'd be kind enough to keep your
cameras on and your microphones muted
unless asked to unmute by the chair and
the rules of debate do apply for this
meeting if you could please speak
through the channel can I can I just say
cancer lilies
um as it sounds raised
together
sorry I cannot hear or see the chair at
all
can you hear me now can you see the
council chamber at all
counselor Lee if
I think you're muted councilor Lily
and we've alsoever
I've got visual but I I haven't got
audio
counselor we're going can you hear me
I can hear you yeah see I've got it I've
I've actually got it on speaker View
so that it just the speaker is on screen
at the moment with a catalog at the side
but I can I've got visual now I'm here
but I haven't got audio on chair
okay hunt if I can just establish
whether that is an issue for all members
or if it's just for counselor Lily
um
other members are indicating chair you
have councilor Burkin who wishes to
speak
thank you chair yeah you come I can see
you chair but I can't pay you very well
you're very very quiet there's if you're
a couple of hundred miles away
and and we've also got counselor uh
Lillian
yeah I can't hear you either
I've got visual but I can't hear you on
that basis chair um if we could just
pause the meeting a moment I'm going to
request ICT to visit you in the chamber
to see if we can resolve that matter
uh just looking there are there any
microphones out in the chamber
yeah I'm just wondering uh can you hear
my microphone all right
yeah
can you hear my microphone
you can so if I swap mine with the chair
it might be that it could be a
microphone issue
and I just interrupt if I may it's
cancer Lucy um actually the microphones
in the chamber are unusually quiet
compared to
um so if it's a connection issue with
the microphones in the urge chamber that
may be at fault there
can I ask can you hear me now
still quiet
it's some it's unusually quiet
um yeah not as it you know the voice is
in the council chamber usually are much
louder than they are today
um it's very quiet and you are very
distant right
I'll try shouting
I think the issue from the the chamber
is that we're using the microphones that
are in front of us but we the one that
is linked to the camera is Switched Off
they don't work in
Unison with one another
I don't like to use the word unison in
public
um
[Laughter]
but uh
well that's I think that's the problem
though I think it's about the um the one
that's linked to the camera
not picking up what we're saying and so
we're relying on the ones that are in
front of us I think we just have to
speak right into the microphone chair
can I ask is that any better
I think men is indicating that that's an
improvement of their chair I do have um
I'm hoping support to come up to you and
hopefully that will that will be soon
um to see if there's anything that could
be done
um in regard to adjusting the volume
levels without interrupting the meeting
um so if you're happy for me to
procedure
thank you
um so
for this meeting
um voting will be conducted um either by
poll or um by roll call where uh we need
to comply with the regulations today to
run recorded votes on the budget issues
um and they will be conducted today in
Reverse alphabetical order uh the chat
function is available
um to contact the facilitation of the
meeting if you want to indicate your
wish to speak and alternatively you can
raise your hand if you um enable your
closed captions you'll see
um that I will type in there to note
when you've been when you've been seen
that you've had your hand up so you
don't necessarily have to keep it raised
for the entire entire time and we will
make sure that we have communication
with the chair to help her uh to see
everybody who wishes to speak
thank you
all right Declarations of Interest
members who have interest should have
declared them to the governance manager
in advance of the meeting just a
reminder that we will consider the
budget at today's meeting I'd like to
ask the monitoring officer for some
advice on the Declarations that need to
be made
excuse me churches before then Javier
started the um audio recording of the
meeting as opposed to the YouTube One
um thank you for the prompt Allen
apologies uh missed that step because
we've interrupted in my speech let me
just record that now you'll hear an
announcement members
this meeting is being recorded
so so thank you thank you Sarah
Steinberg monitoring officer just a
brief resume of the interest issues for
today's meeting we have the budget on
the agenda so if a member is two months
or more behind on the council tax
payments they will not be allowed to
take part in the vote on any budgetary
matters and must declare this at the
start of the meeting please note that
not doing so is a criminal offense under
section 106 for the local government
Finance Act 1992.
next if a member is a tenant in a
council owned property they must declare
an interest in any item relating to the
budget setting process however they will
still be permitted to speak and vote on
the item for those affected please will
you put on the chat line Council tenants
so we can pick this up for the minutes
members are also reminded that votes on
any item relating to council tax or the
budget will be taken by roll call and
recorded in a minute as a requirement of
the local authorities standing orders
England Amendment regulations
next members who sit on kilimage Parish
Council have a significant other
interest in sections of the mtfp item
members appointed to serve on the
rignard homes board have dpi's
disclosable pecuniar interests which
must also be declared
significant other interests and dpis
requires those members to withdraw to a
waiting room of the appropriate at the
appropriate time these are councilors
clef pots white and k-bone p-bone for
kilimash Leisure Center and then
council's Oscar Gomez Rini Diana Ralph
and Steve Clough for the ricknold homes
items
can members please indicate if they have
any interest to declare my apologies I
should have said we will also do show
hands in a minute for Council house
tenants can members please indicate if
they have any interest to declare other
than there's a council house tenant
thank you
counselor Lily
yeah I'd need to declare interests on
items seven on the agenda because I am a
council tenant
uh in the chat function always to have
decorations uh from Council Hall and
councilor Pickering
counselor Canyon
uh yes thank you Chad I'm not sure if we
need to declare it but uh we've got
joint venture Northwood and um I'm one
of the direct
it's not peculiar interesting Northwood
as a director of our joint venture
we'll note that
yeah I also have a declaration on chat
form councilor Pam windley
is there any
Twitter show
Caster Hill is indicating a wish to
speak
councilor Hill
yeah thank you chair I don't know
whether I've got to declare I'm not on
retinal board on the Community Committee
that was set up
uh I don't know whether that makes any
difference or not
no chair I wouldn't have thought that
needed
okay thank you
Claire Castle Club is also indicating
his wish to speak
slabone
councilor Kevin bone declaring an
interesting for Clermont
thank you
as I'm not sure you heard where you
would hear me but as I said all the
members of the kilimage parish council
should declare an interest and all the
board members of Rick Lord should
declare an interest
thank you
all right councilor off
hello
I have declare an interest regarding
Rick North board
thank you
and chair councilor Gomez Brina just
declaren an interest rignal board
from an interesting killer Marsh Parish
Council and Rick millboard
chair councilor waiter declaring an
interest in kilimash Parish Council and
Northwood group Limited
also indicating chair
uh councilor Parks killer Marsh Westward
declaring an interest in item number
seven section 6.3 and 6.13
Ad Council Pat bone is also indicating
sure yeah
um an interest is kind of marsh Parish
Council
all right can we go to the minutes of
the last meeting can we approve the
minutes of the last meeting as a true
and accurate record may I remind members
that the content of the minutes can only
be discussed in relation to accuracy and
are not for debating please can I have a
mover to accept the minutes of the last
meeting as a true and accurate record
councilor Dale
yeah thank you happy to move the minutes
thank you we are seconded
okay
you had both councilor Hancock and
cancer cupist indicating
thank you
councilor Cooper
just a second the minutes thank you
chair
thanks
foreign
it was only to Second as well chair
because I couldn't see any other hands
up
thank you
yeah would you like for me to launch the
poll
yes please
members you'll have a poll in front of
you asking you to uh vote for against or
abstain
um approval of the minutes held on the
11th of January 2021
thank you
just a few more votes to come through
a few more seconds
and they'll end the poll there with 100
of online voting 43 for um
shared your votes for against abstaining
the chamber
yes there's two four in the chamber
that's Carrie chair
liquor before we go any further can I
ask you if you can speak up that little
bit more because I'm a bit difficult to
hearing you
of course chair is that better that's
better thank you
this has been a very difficult year for
fundraising for my chairs Charities but
I'd like to express my sincere thanks
to all who have made a donation and to
those Parish councils I've offered
donations it is greatly appreciated
thank you
we'll have our leaders announcement
thank you chair
um while it remains an extremely
challenging time for our district as the
virus continues to cause Devastation in
its wake I am heartened that we are
beginning to see a steadying and
dropping off in rates and I say this
keeping everything crossed but we also
now appear to have gone beyond the peak
in terms of hospitalizations and it's
hoped that within the coming weeks the
Chesterfield Royal will be able to
regain some of the capacity uh which has
been stretched under tremendous pressure
over the past couple of months there is
further light at the end of the tunnel
due to the ramping up of the vaccination
program across our area and I'm aware
from several meetings that we've
attended in recent weeks that
significant progress is being made in
the top four priority groups and I'm
assured that we are well on track to
meet the national targets of completing
those priority groups by the middle of
this month as you'll know we are doing
our bits of support the vaccination
program and Charlie Park Leisure Center
has become a key Center to support the
vaccination of our residents and we
continue to offer the ccgs and the
primary care networks whatever
assistance we can to support the rollout
as well as supporting Community testing
around the county which is helping to
identify and isolate any asymptomatic
carriers of the virus in saying all of
this of course we continue to mourn the
loss of life due to covid over the
course of this pandemic something which
we know the council itself has very
sadly not been immune to I'm sure you
will all join me in saying that our
thoughts and condolences are very firmly
with those who have lost loved ones due
to this Dreadful virus
despite the glimmers of light at the end
of the tunnel I'm sure we all know
someone in our Lives who has been
directly affected and this bring brings
home the devastating impact that kovid
can still reap on our lives and we owe
it to all those who have sadly succumbed
to the virus to keep following the rules
uh as closely as we possibly can to
limit the spread this I think is the
most fitting way that we can pay our
respects to those we have lost
going back to the subject of hospitals
members may recall that Council Ridgeway
raised the issue of the possible
reintroduction of parking charges for
NHS staff a couple of a couple of
meetings ago I recently wrote to the
chief executive of the trust that runs
the Jessica Royal
um to highlight the concerns over this
issue and whilst also passing on our
thanks to all NHS staff for the amazing
work that they're doing at this very
difficult time and to offer any support
to the hospital that they may need from
the council last week I received a reply
from the chief executive as follows I
would like to extend my thanks to you
and your council members for your offer
of help during these challenging times
your elected members are correct our
staff are working extremely hard and
under more pressure than we saw in the
first wave of the pandemic with this in
mind charging staff for on-site parking
is something that we are not planning on
reintroducing at this time I would like
to thank you again for your kind
comments regarding the hard-working
members of Staff here at the trust and
for your kind offer of assistance I hope
members will agree that this is good
news and is a very welcome decision by
the trust
I also just want to highlight that our
officers are continuing to work very
hard to get the business support grants
out to do businesses who are facing
difficulties due to covid we've had many
millions of pounds that we've been able
to distribute since the start of the
pandemic bringing a vital Lifeline to
many businesses who have clearly been
hit very hard as I've stated previously
the schemes are not without their
complexity so if members do have any
queries on behalf of local businesses
please do get in touch with either
Council parking or myself and we will
gladly look into any issues finally Cher
I also just want to draw members
attention to a few recent items of news
from the council firstly our next
Community Action grants round is due to
open for applications and it's available
to those Community groups who are
working to tackle local issues in our
district more details can be found on
the website and I'd ask members to
support the council in raising awareness
of the scheme within our communities
the councils also received feedback a
feedback report on the Beat the Street
initiative in Clay Cross where 2001
sorry 2170 people participated in the
scheme and collectively traveled over 9
700 miles across the area the report
highlights the positive impacts that the
program has had on physical inactivity
in the community and it's been really
great to see some of the feedback from
participants who have noticed not just
the impact on their physical but also
their Mental Health
and finally I also just want to
highlight and congratulate one of our
employees Abdul Hakeem who on winning a
national uh coach Corps award for
Apprentice of the year now Abdul came to
the country from Ethiopia as another
company teenager seeking Asylum just a
few years ago and he secured an
apprenticeship within our Leisure
service and is now well on the way to
achieving his lifeguard qualifications
at Charlie Park he's clearly overcome
some tremendous challenges in order to
succeed not least the language barrier
and get into grips with the Derbyshire
dialect on behalf of the council can I
say how proud We Are of Abdul on this
fantastic achievement
and before I finish here can I also
thank you once again and the officers
that have been supporting you in raising
money for your appeal Charities despite
the very obvious challenges faced uh due
to covid and once again ask that all
members do whatever we can to support
the chair and these vital charities in
the coming months thank you very much
thank you
Council Ridgeway yeah I'd just like to
say thank you to the leader councilor
Dale for your letter to the hospital it
means a lot not just to me but to
anybody else who's working for the NHS
during this very difficult time and I'd
just like to thank you for that
thank you
I can confirm that we have received one
question from the public
Mr sourday is in attendance but has
asked for this to be read out on her
behalf
please can I ask Alan in the governance
team to read out a question to the
portfolio order for leisure
transformation and climate change
thank you chair and the question is as
follows
uh the Northeast Derbyshire climate
action plan 2019 contains a promise to
develop a climate change communication
strategy
as we know good communication is a
process of sharing information
and also of listening to other points of
view
I've been very disappointed in the
council's inability to consult and
listen to the people of Northeast
Derbyshire on the subject of local
climate action
to date your communication with the
public on the topic of climate change
has consisted of one short online snap
survey an information piece in the news
publication
on one on what individuals can do to
reduce their carbon emissions
under one page climate change statement
on the council website that has not been
updated for a year
you have previously used the covet
pandemic as a justification for your
lack of action in this area of public
consultation
but other local councils are
successfully engaging with their local
residents on climate action despite the
coverage restrictions
Derbyshire Dales District Council is
appointing a climate officer
who will work with Partners businesses
residents and The Wider Community to
influence positive environmental action
this Council has also welcomed
involvement from The Hub a group of
residents who have come together to
offer help and support to the council in
developing strategies to address climate
change issues
Chesterfield Borough Council held a
process of public engagement earlier
this year
with a series of meetings where a
cross-section of local residents were
involved in consultation about the
development of the climate plan
and they already have a climate offer
climate officer in place
Chesterfield Council have created an
active web page sharing information
about climate strategies
and long-term Communications and
engagement strategy is being developed
with an emphasis on partnership and
collaborative working
the council have consulted the resident
group Chesterfield climate Alliance on
both of the above actions
as the Northeast Derbyshire climate
action plan theme six community and
collaboration clearly recognizes the
role of community engagement on this
issue
can you explain how you propose to
improve your process of Consulting and
working collaboratively with the wider
community on this very urgent issue
of the climate emergency and that's the
end of the question chair thank you
thank you
councilor Kenyon
um thank you chair
um hello Mrs though day and thank you
for your question though I say I don't
accept the premise of it and I do
believe our record on community and
collaboration is excellent
it's good to hear other councils are
Consulting on the climate strategies but
we've had our own strategy for 18 months
now and of course we welcome any
feedback on it and we're currently
revising it so that will be timely but
the purpose of a strategy is not to
consult on it produce it and talk about
it but to implement it
our strategy has themes covering every
section of our Council so a nominal
climate change officer simply does not
cut the mustard either
we have embedded green thinking
throughout our organization and it's on
our the agenda of all our management
from bins to planning Leisure centers to
housing and I'm very proud of how all
our officers have visited the climate
challenge even through covid
business activities include spending
Millions to improve installation on our
worst insulated Council housing
installing LED lighting in our business
units supporting home working to reduce
travel investing in Energy Efficiency at
our Leisure centers preparing to switch
to 100 renewable electricity and giving
Eco grants to our schools
on the community and collaboration theme
covert is not an excuse but it is
unfortunately a grim fact but even so we
have made extensive progress during
covid we produced a parish climate pack
which has been shared all across of
Derbyshire specifically to help Parish
councils develop their own employment
plans and just last week I was at a
meeting with three Parish councils
hearing about their climate plans and
sharing some of ours
working collaboratively is building
Partnerships with other organizations
such as our neighboring councils and
schools because the reality is we have
to think at scale to achieve serious
decarbonization
so our officers are taking the lead
across Derbyshire on a variety of
climate related projects ranging from
housing insulation to electric car
charging
this includes a major Community project
we call thanks a ton this project
recognizes the need to reach the large
number of residents who do not live and
breathe climate issues and has been
developed using expertise from
behavioral scientists
I remember the blue Peter thermometers
that used to be used to enthused kids
and give them targets thanks a ton aims
to bring that sense of achievement to
climate change Michelin will work with
schools to engage kids parents and
grandparents in making pledges to take
specific actions to reduce their carbon
footprint who claim those pledges and
give clear thermometer style feedback so
our residents can see the impact of lots
of small actions as well as the larger
ones
this is so day I truly share your sense
of urgency and our officers will voucher
how hard I push them on climate matters
I do have to be mindful of how our
resource is used and while we counselors
love to talk this Administration goal
and that of our climate strategy is to
reduce hot air and not increase it I
believe actions speak louder than words
and our actions on climate change speak
very loudly indeed
that said I've recently had two requests
from climate groups with good expertise
including your group and so what I
propose to do is set up an online
meeting to discuss our strategy together
and they will contact your group in the
next few days about that thank you
thank you
Mrs Powell no do you wish to ask a
supplementary question
it must be a question not a statement or
a comment
yes I'd like to ask a supplementary
question please good afternoon
counselors good afternoon councilor
Canyon thank you for your response
um
I recognize that the council as a whole
has taken many steps in um carbon
reduction but the steps you've described
are nowhere near what's required to show
leadership and engage the public
um and meet the level of actions we
should expect from the council in
addressing the climate crisis the
actions you've described
her son account business rather than
reaching out to The Wider community and
trying to engage people and
organizations in other ways I think
you've got a much broader role than your
own council's business
um as you acknowledged
um there's there's a new group in setup
in Northeast Derbyshire it was only set
up two weeks ago it's called climate
action in Northeast Derbyshire this is
so
um it is a question I'll get to my
question
um and we already have 46 members signed
up from across Northeast Derbyshire
given that local people are
demonstrating such a desire to be
involved in developing responses to
climate change councilor Kenyon would
you firstly commit to not singly an
online meeting but creating an active
Forum in which local people can meet
with the council to collaborate in
developing a climate action plan and
secondly would you commit to appointing
a climate officer who will facilitate
collaboration between local residents
and the council in responding to the
climate emergency
uh thank you Mrs third day um I'm a bit
perplexed because I just described a
whole series of actions that we have
taken working with our community
I think it's important to point out that
we have a hundred thousand residents in
our district and reaching that hundred
thousand residents is is the priority
for our theme six in our climate
strategy
um you know we've got to
and carry that larger population with us
and um like you I'm one of the enthusia
Enthusiast is the wrong word I take a
very keen interest in this matter
because I can see the long-term uh
consequences of it but we have to focus
on taking that broad majority with us uh
I already answered about the climate
officer it's it's much deeper than one
person to be a figurehead for a council
it's got to be top to bottom throughout
your Council and I will stick with that
as uh there's my answer to that
um I'll as I said I will arrange a
meeting with yourselves in the the
client group you referred to as the
other group actually
um having a forum is all very well and
uh
and my office as well know that we've
talked about
um some of the options there and I'll
carry on considering that and see what
can be done that we have to focus on the
hundred thousand residents not on uh
small groups of individuals within that
and that's that's got to be my priority
and our council's priority thank you
thank you that concludes today's public
questions
to present the report on the medium-term
financial plan
thank you chair uh I believe that uh
some members uh
the killer Marsh
County need to leave yeah yes
okay with your permission chair and the
permission of those members I'm just
going to
um just put those members who have
indicated in uh waiting room
thank you watch the Youtube video
the um the meeting is
like YouTube feed is live if you didn't
want to watch it
okay
thank you
boy she's just taking a few moments
excuse me Nikki do you want me to
actually press to leave this meeting or
are you going to move me into the
waiting room
foreign
yes I'm putting you into the waiting
room now
are there any members that remain that
need to go into a waiting room could you
please indicate now
is Council Club still on the call yeah
he's indicating Nikki thanks
apologies I'm having some technical
issues I do apologize
foreign
still here
fine now
thank you councilor Parkin
thank you chair
um the first step is the uh approval of
the budget for the killer Marsh Leisure
Center so
um members will recall on uh 11th of
January report was presented to this
Council in respect to kill a marsh
Leisure Center the proposed budgets have
now been included in the general form
for approval as part of this budget
setting process and can be found out
appendix 2 in the appended mtfp cabinet
report
um a budget for the refurbishment of
killer Marsh Leisure Center has been
included in the program for
2021-22
and we have a couple of recommendations
um but I'll pass it back to the chair
for questions and comments
foreign
councilor Dale
yeah thank you Joe I'm happy to move uh
I think it's recommendation 6.3 and 6.13
we're moving is it at this stage
yeah if there are no comments chair um
I'm happy to propose it or second
whichever uh 6.3 and 6.13
accounts
uh barkers indicating chair
thanks chair I didn't realize that uh
we're gonna do it like this uh to be
perfectly honest I mean it passed we've
either moved
uh so are we saying we're splitting
these are we going out in one at a time
then or what what what's happening uh
I suppose in that respect if you're
doing 6.3 and 6.13 we're back where
we're last time and uh
and we'll we'll just abstain from those
because uh we I don't think like we
spent last time that we've got enough
information or a business case to to
fully support it we're not against it
we'd like to see a kill of my Leisure
Center but I think uh with I assume we
were taking them all all on block well
the general form first and the revenue
account and then the capital program so
you just need a bit of clarity really
why are we doing like this
if I might uh I don't know if you could
hear me but at the beginning I was
explaining that killer Marsh Leisure
Center uh district and Parish Council
was as Paris councilors have a
significant other interest that they
needed to declare and they needed to be
away from the room for discussion of the
budget so we've had to put the budget
into chunks the first being the killer
Marsh Leisure Center then we'll deal
with the general fund and ultimately
housing revenue account where of course
the writtenald board members will have
to leave for prior to discussion
I didn't understand it like that to be
honest Sarah I I assumed they were
leaving foot locked but there you go
there's no need to leave for a lot
um their interest stretches to kill
emotional Leisure Center not the whole
budget
hmm
counselor Birkin
nope
councilor Hancock's indicating chair I'm
Frank
thank you chair
um I'm I'm actually
just taking issue a little bit with what
the monitoring officer has said because
this is presented this talking about as
part of this budget we're either
approving the whole thing as the general
fund and the HRA as we normally do or or
we're just taking every little bit line
by line which is absolutely useless
um that that this is just not the proper
form this has been presented to us as a
single report it is a single agenda item
as I said we've always done this in
relation to Rick nod
um housing board members because they
have interests that they need to declare
a killer Marsh Leisure Center is no
different so it's been split off
it is difficult to see how they could be
how their interests could be dealt with
without removing them from discussion
and budgets which they should be able to
discuss without doing it this way
councilor Dale
all right just just to come back on that
point as well I mean my understanding is
that that's uh in a perfect world any
report would be dealt with
recommendation by recommendation it's
just that the the custom and practice of
how we deal with reports usually is to
deal with recommendations on block uh
but there is no reason why we couldn't
deal with it in this way and I think it
would be unfair to uh to uh the killer
Marsh members for them not to be able to
vote on the rest of the budget where it
where it's not relevant to kilimar so I
personally think that it's this is the
appropriate way to deal with it
um and this is this is the way that it
should be done but that's my perspective
thank you Jeff yeah
Angela Birkin
thank you chair councilor Joe Burke in
uh Sutton Ward
um the difficulty that I have with this
if we are saying that counselors from
kilimash need to uh cannot be involved
in this aspect of uh of this of uh
supporting or otherwise these
recommendations when we've dealt with
that part then the rest of the
um the rest of the recommendations the
general fund in total will Encompass
whatever has been decided Visa via
kilimash though those members will then
be voting with an element of the
kilimash decision uh as part and parcel
of the overall decision surely that is a
an item where they have uh peculiar
interests involved
yeah
if I might the intention is to vote on
the kilimarsh Pacific recommendations
and then to take the rest of the general
fund recommendations together so no that
decision will have been made one way or
the other by the time those members
return to vote on the rest of the
general fund
thank you
Council Birkin
thank you chair sorry to our plan but
surely that decision will affect the
general fund it must do we've not got
two two bags of money out there have we
or are there more than that
yeah the decision though will have been
taken on killer Marshall Leisure Center
it will be done and dusted you you will
be looking at the other recommendations
on the other aspects of the general fund
as a point of order
um how are we actually following the
debate on this because we've got a
single agenda item so people are allowed
to speak once but we're taking it as
piecemeal when people may have an issue
to raise on the killer Marsh
specifically and then have another issue
to raise on the remainder on the
remainder of it we're being told at the
start of this meeting the normal rules
of Dubai to play but this isn't normal
rules of debate
yes
it's perfectly acceptable for members to
speak once on each of the sections
clearly there are three separate debates
even though they're within the same
report
I want to order a chair that's just not
correct interpretation of that because
in the in the Constitution it says
nothing about you can start taking it
apart it talks about amendments that you
can speak on and so forth it doesn't
talk about having one notion that you
can pull apart into different debates
so I'll take exception that the
monitoring officers is trying to elude
that that's what it says because it just
simply does not say that
that is the view we've taken over the
number of years that is the way we've
always done it in relation to Rick nold
with all due respect Sarah just because
you take the view on that does not make
that a lawful thing to be doing in a
council meeting story but that's not how
it works and as we have discussed many
times it's really down to the chairman
and what she wishes to do in terms of
running the meeting so you so you're
telling council members that basically
you profiled it into a meeting
and then because it's now in full floor
in the meeting
you're not gonna
apply the Constitution because it's up
to the chair I'm sorry about that's
unacceptable even we're taking this on
block which includes like councilor
Birkin says the killer March support
center which the decision at the end
will be taking that pot of money into
into the result of the motion so I don't
understand how you can just pull that
out of the budget that was devoted it
first and then want killer Marsh members
to come in and vote on the budget which
that will involve
it has been noted but we will Press On
any more comments
comes the Kenyan
yes I'd just like to point out that
every Council has sat in this meeting
has got Parish councils uh just about
everybody that they're responsible for
spending by the district will affect
many of those situations whether it's
the contracts or play areas that street
scene do you name it I'd also point out
this specifically with killer Marsh
Sports Center this council at the very
previous meeting discussed this issue
and agreed to support it without the
killer Marsh counselors there so it's
the best covered issue compared to what
sits there every other council meeting
and certainly have a budget meeting
all right so we'll go to the vote on
this
okay
the second door for this so yeah
you don't need it nope that's up to the
vote
this needs to be a recorded vote
apologies yes I had admitted that fact I
will do a recorded vote I will call out
your names in turn as ever starting from
the end
councilor P Wright
Chad could we just have a just a
reminder that we're what we're voting on
the recommendations it's 6.3 and 6.13 am
I am I correcting that
yes chair that's correct and only those
two
so cancer P right yes four
Council winley
against
Council Welton or Council Thacker
for cancer Tate
or cancer Stone
[Music]
apologies I've got my mic muted then I'm
staying thank you
Council Shipman
cancer ruff
or cancer row
four
that's a Ridgeway
abstain
Council Renwick
for
Council reader
abstain
councilor pal oh
councilor Pickering
abstain
cancer parking
four
Council Lily
abstain
cancer Liggett
or
counselors
councilor Kerry
I'm scale councilor Kenyon or Council
Jones
abstain
Council Hutchinson
or
cancer Hill
abstain cancer Hawthorne
same Council Hancock against councilor
Hall
cancer Gomez Rini
oh
cancer for now
or
cancer Mark Foster or Council Angelique
Foster
for cancer emins
four
councilor Elliott
or
cancer Dayton four cancer Dale or cancer
Cupid for Council Cornwall
abstain that's the Cooper abstain
councilor Burkin abstain
Council Barker
staying Council Armitage
for councilor and Cliff four
[Music]
laughs
foreign
25 against 3 and 13 abstentions
it's carried thank you
now chair we have to bring the other
members back for the next part of the
debate
[Music]
all those members are joining us now
chair
thank you
first five members are back in the
meeting room
thank you
Council Parkin
thank you chair uh and now we've come to
the um to the remainder of the
recommendations for the uh for this
paper which is uh the approval of the
general form budget so
as you'll appreciate this has been a
very challenging budget setting process
um with the pandemic
uh leading to uncertainty around the
proposed national settlement for the
years
21-22 a settlement was released on the
17th of December and was effectively a
further rollover of the uh 2015
settlement
the settlements also included a series
of measures specifically targeting uh as
you know with assisting the financial
challenges that local authorities across
the country have been facing as a result
of covid-19
and some of the settlement elements were
a three-year spread of collection fund
losses
support where the ability to Levy
council tax on business rates has been
reduced as a result of a pandemic so
we've had that and that's the ltics or
local taxation income compensation
scheme uh a continuation of the income
compensation scheme philosophies and
charges into quarter one of 2021 22 and
the final tranche of uh covered Grant so
he's Financial pressure pressures
um there's also been a one-off lower
tier Services Grant so the rollover of
the 2015 settlement for a further year
means that the charges the changes that
we expected from the spending review
such as abolition of new homes bonus
business rates reform and fair funding
review won't now affect the 2021 budget
which which removes the majority of the
budget pressures that we identified in
last year's mtfp
this means that means that along with
the covered measures previously
mentioned
a balanced budget can be set for next
year
however it is fully expected that the
spending review that will inform the
following Year's budget will take place
so the pressures previously identified
and effectively been put back a year and
there is so far very little detail as to
what that spending review will look like
at this stage but we fully expect the
abolition of the new homes bonus and a
reset of business rates to go ahead
along with some Equalization in the way
spending need is assessed so we have to
plan cautiously
this means that whilst a balanced
general fund budget can be set for 21.22
the savings Targets in future years
remain challenging
and this means there's still
guns
during the pandemic it's been
challenging to maintain momentum on
growth and transformation agenda and
this along with robust budget management
process across all service areas will be
a key priority in 2021.
as in previous years the an upper limit
is set for council tax increases
nationally this year as in previous
years it's set at 1.99 or five pounds
whichever is the greater
there is an increasing Reliance in the
current funding system for councils to
fund
services from increases in council tax
but we need to balance
the need to generate our ongoing Revenue
against the impact on our taxpayers
especially at this particular time
we are therefore proposing an increase
of 1.95 which is three pounds 70 on a
Bundy in 2021-22
okay
uh the general fund budget proposed
for
fixed one in the uh appended mtfb
cabinet report and the 2021 estimated
outcome is forecast to balanced uh using
reserves to meet the impact of covet
table one shows the budget position for
2021 onwards uh sorry 2021-22 onwards
and you'll note that the
2021-22 budget has a small full of
0.110133 million which is fully fully
expected to be met from vacancy
management
from 2022 onwards the budget shortfalls
Falls increase due to the previously
mentioned charges uh changes expected in
the 2022 spending review
budgets are wherever possible cash
limited uh with increased costs being
met from efficiencies
a rigorous savings Target for
transformation has been included but
more work will be needed to close the
gap in later years and in respect of the
general form of capital program the
budget proposed for approval can be
found in appendix for in the appended
ntfb cabinet report the increases from
2022 reflect the vehicle replacement
program
uh thank you chair uh I would like to
move some recommendations but I'll come
back to them I just want to see whether
there's any comments or questions
come come have a moment second there
please
I'll I'll move chair I'll move the
recommendations just so that uh so that
they are moved so I'd like to move the
recommendation 6.1 and 6.2
then 6.4 to 6.6 and then 6.14 in respect
to the general fund please
councilor Dale yeah I'm happy to Second
those recommendations so 6.1 to uh 6.4
6.5 6.6 and 6.14 that's cancel parking
set
I'm so Barker
thank you chair
it's quite ironic this I've written a
speech here and I were going to support
a lot but you gave us opportunity
because I didn't think we could split it
up into sections so there you go so I'll
have to rip my speech up and start again
uh I mean I will accept its difficult
times you know from our group and we are
trying to work constructive
constructively together you know with
with the issues that were that we're
facing and all that sort of stuff so
uh we're prepared to vote and I I think
you've said in your the blame that that
1.95 percent
uh
well it's not the maximum you could go
up to five quid and all that and I think
you it's a balance there uh we can
accept that
just we had got a couple issues uh 6.1
which we've not talked about yet uh
whilst we accept that uh the Chief
Financial Officer or James view that the
estimates are all busting the level of
financial reserves are adequate that's
what she says
uh but we do have concerns going forward
that uh about the state of the the
council finances and uh I can't help but
keep referring back to table one that's
on page 21 of the pack
that uh that when we get back in power
in 2023 we're going to be a million
pound sure so we're we're keeping an eye
on them budgets uh and it gets worse
after that probably but we're accepting
and also with the killer Marsh thing you
know obviously we've already decided
that so uh but we've all the caveats
that we raised at the last meeting still
old about this this is not an ideal time
to be taking on an extra financial
responsibility when we've got all these
other issues well we'll leave that so
yeah uh we're happy to to support
there was numbers excluding 6.3 and six
point wherever it were to the that we've
already decided on
so and we'll come back to the HRA attack
it when the original people have uh left
us which we always do I accept that but
that's because of the rent setting and
and the complications there I'm sure
we've asked in the past to take
individual items out one at a time and
it's not been allowed well there you go
thank you
councilor Foster first and then
councilor and Carl uh thank you chair I
did originally put my hand up to second
but uh our Leader's done that so I'll
leave that one thank you
um first to cover
um councilor Barker's point about going
back in power that's not happening we
know it's not happening it won't
uh I'd also like to speak in support of
uh this these recommendations and this
balanced budget put forward by councilor
parking uh and what I'd like to focus on
is the help that we've received from uh
central government
that's been huge uh the figures are 20
20 21 up to now
the provided through the contract 7.2
billion pounds of additional expenditure
funding for local authorities
and most of that has been in non-ring
friends Grands which means local
councils have been able like ourselves
to respond to local pressures and local
priorities and spend spending how we
need to spend it so not to take anything
away from uh from the work of councilor
parking and the work of our finance
officer but you know it's a part of what
we've been able to do in producing this
robust budget as being what central
government's done it's been the monies
that's been distributed and on time and
in the right way so not stick it away
from your Council parking but yeah
between the three of the essential
government yourself and our officers
we've got a balanced budget and I'm
happy to recommend it
thank you councilor Hancock
thank you chair I think I'm actually
going to be a less insulting to
councilor parking because I I think yeah
the bailout has helped but it was it was
exceptional times
so my uh my key concern and I mean I
said last year and and none of us could
have forecast what what's happened but I
did say last year it was a mistake by
not raising council tax then because
because of situations obviously we've
had to this time
exactly the same concerns as I did last
time
um counselor counselor Barker has
touched on them this is going to leave
us with a huge mess
um and there's there's no getting away
from that unless central government
bails out again
um it
the the difficulty is
um and and we we can't support it
because it is the medium-term financial
plan and the short term is balanced
going forward we're not we've got
um well I mean it's a slightly improved
position but we're looking at a 1.6
million deficit
in in the matter of a couple of years
time
and there's nothing in here to address
that position there's nothing of
substance and what we keep hearing or
the implication that I'm getting from
what we're hearing is that we're reliant
on people leaving well sooner or later
we'll have no staff left
um and then we've still got to find
savings from somewhere
um
I openly admit I I am I didn't support
I'm reluctant because I think taking on
the killer Marsh project at this time
with these figures in front of us is a
huge mistake
um so my concern is yes I I actually I
do give councilor parking credit for the
work he's done over the last year and on
the short-term budget absolutely but my
concerns here we're looking at the
medium term and the medium term is not
good and and I'm afraid on that basis we
will actually be voting against it
thank you before we go to the vote is
anyone else who wishes to speak
cancer parking yeah if I may yes uh
thank you very much and thank you for uh
for the uh for the comments on the
budget uh councilor Barker uh
appreciated although unfortunately like
counselor Foster I can't see one of
those predictions coming true but we'll
see
um as far as the uh the remainder of the
mtfp is concerned the the reason that
the predictions the models the that are
that are there are so high the 1.6
million uh it is frankly because we
don't know what the settlement will be
in 2022 yet uh and once we have that
information uh we we hope to be able to
revise those long-term figures uh
downwards and uh and then we'll have a
much more uh a much more comprehensive
view of what might happen in uh towards
2023 where Mr Bach when councilor
Barker's concern seems to arise most but
thank you for the comments and uh I'd
also like to say that I will take the
credit for this balanced budget uh this
has been the work of our finance team uh
they have a section 151 officer and
ethic who has put an enormous amount of
work into this to get us to the point
where we can balance the budget so thank
you all the finance team thank you chair
bye to you
we are now going to the vote
thank you chair
um as before this will be in reverse
order I'll read your names out in turn
please tell me which way you wish to
vote
right Council right or
Council winley
can I clarify this as a tenant I'm okay
to vote Yes right thank you uh against
Council Whitehead
four
Council Welton
or Council Thacker
for cancer Tate or cancer Stone
sorry keep forgetting all new for thank
you Council Shipman
absolutely against
cancer rough
counselor Rowe
for
Council Ridgeway
four
Council Renwick
Council reader
four councilor pal
oh councilor Potts
four and it's the Pickering
oh that's the parking
or Council Lily
or
cancer Liggett or
counselor Lewis
or councilor Kerry
and that's a canyon
or Council Jones
four
Council Hutchinson
councilor Hill
or councilor hartshorn or Council
Hancock
sorry chair from Strongsville mute
against
the hall
four
cancer Gomez Rini
or Council for now
four
Council Mark Foster
Dayton
four answer Dale or that's a Cupid
Council Cornwall
[Music]
come on
yeah
[Music]
the result is it's carried 43
four three against and no abstentions
thank you
coming up now the Rick nulled
people to leave
Chad I'm just going to
um to put the three members you
indicated in in the room thank you
so that's cancer Steve Clough Castle
Oscar Gomez really and counselor Diana
Ruff and all of those around the waiting
room
thank you
councilor Parkin
thank you chair
um so now we come to the HRA so no major
budget pressures have been identified
when setting the housing revenue account
or HRA budget and the HRA budget
proposed for approval can be found at
appendix 3 in the amended mtfb cabinet
report uh mata's letter I'd like to draw
your attention to are
rent and National Rent guidance has been
followed for this year CPI plus one as
this Council has done for many years uh
equaling 1.5 percent as with Council
council tax setting the impact on
tenants has to be balanced with our
needs to generate uh additional Revenue
as the HRA is effectively self-financed
annual rent increases are fundamental to
ensuring that our homes continue to be
well maintained and managed
following engagement with us rhl have
cash limited their management fee for
2021-22 a fee of
9.692 million is proposed for approval
an increase in investment for
non-traditional properties is proposed
for 20 uh sorry 2020
I do apologize
2021 22 seem to be going back in time uh
to complete the uh Eco works that we've
that we've got ongoing and were
mentioned by
um by uh councilor Kenyan earlier on
uh so this has been brought forward in
the program thanks to uh thanks to a
successful claim uh of a million
pounding grant funding
uh so uh sending your comments I'd like
to
uh move the recommendation 6.7 to
6.12 and 6.14 in respect of the HRA
thank you chair
assistant councilor Dale
happy second year
councilor Barker
oh thank you chair yeah uh can I just
refer you to is it 1.36 on page
26 of the fact
just the top page should that be saying
April 2021 instead of 2020. no social
housing rent standing comes in divorce
comes into four so is that a wrong date
I'm just
uh just questioning that and and also
um
sorry well I don't know we but when we
were in control where the government
were more or less setting the rent for
us and telling us to put it down or
wherever
uh it's it appears then that we've no
control over the rent setting am I right
in that that basically this 1.5 is the
government set that uh am I correcting
in assuming that uh and and that date
should be 2021 is it it's a bit pedantic
well it just means that uh it makes more
sense uh
and and like I say that that 1.5 is a
government increase really not ours
for an answer to that please and and and
if that's which I think's the case then
we'll we'll have to we agree to it
thank you counselor and Clark
thank you chair
um just just brought it gay it's it's
there we support this one um it's good
again that we're paying attention to our
non-standard constructions
um just as a point of clarity from
councilor parking that the answer is
normally no it's not an issue so I
suspect it will be exactly the same this
year
um the 611 I'm assuming we haven't had
to make any cash advances for cash flow
purposes and I'm assuming we're not
going to need to or it's not anticipated
that's all the points I have chair
thanks
thank you
any other comments
I'll probably come back later if that's
okay
unless there's any other comments
oh councilor Parkin okay thank you chair
um councilor Barker the date is 2020
that's when the standard came in so
um that's that's why it's that's why
it's dated 2020. uh as far as the rent
setting is concerned yes it's uh you
know it's a standard uh a standard scale
if you like and
as we've done previously in in this
Council we followed the government
recommendations on rents uh and uh we're
doing the same thing right now okay
um
and um
I think we could we could have called
Severance lower but uh as it happens
the CPI is at 0.5 at the moment on the
recommendation from the government is
CPI plus one
um
councilor Hancock
um no we've not had to do any uh
advances cash Advantage so thank you for
asking but no we've not had to do any uh
we don't anticipate any at this point
thank you chair should we move to the
vote
thank you
we shall now go to the vote
thank you chair
as before in reverse order
I'll read each of your names in turn
councilor P right
councilor winley but that's the
Whitehead or Council welcome
or
yeah it's a Thacker or Council Tate or
cancer stage
or that's the then oh
that's a row
or Council Ridgeway
four
cancer Remick
Council reader or
Council Powell oh
Council pots
for that's the Pickering for councilor
Parkin
four Council Lily
or Council Liggett
for Council Lewis or
councilor Kerry
four
Council Canyon or
Council Jones or
cancer Hutchinson
four
four thank you councilor Hill
bouncer Hill
sorry for
Council Hearts horn
councilor Hancock four
councilor Hall
[Music]
cancer for now
for cancer Mark Foster
four Council Angelique Foster
four councilor Emmons or counselor
Elliott or councilor Dayton
four Council Dale
or Council Cupid
or cancer Cornwall or announcer Cooper
four councilor Pat bone
four cancer
four
councilor Burkin
for Council Barker well
councilor Armitage
for
cancer and Cliff four
you anonymous
okay I have a request to a few members
would like a short break
and we um but just I'm sure it'll break
as quickly as possible back please
[Music]
two
chair we're now backup and live
thank you
I'll call you more find your mom
oh
the treasury management strategy can I
invite councilor Parkin portfolio order
for finance to present the report on the
treasury management strategy
thank you very much chair
um
and thank you for the break uh so the
purpose of this report is to provide
counsel with the necessary information
to approve the council's suite of
Treasury strategies for 2021 22 through
to 20 24 25 it says here
um we're approving them for this year
um so as part of the requirements of the
Sip for
uh treasury management code of practice
council is required to produce every
year A treasury management strategy and
capital strategy which requires approval
by full Council prior to the
commencement of each Financial year and
these reports that you have in front of
you uh hopefully have in front of you uh
are prepared in order to comply with
these obligations
um
I don't have much to say about these
other than to point out in 6.2 the
Prudential indicators and the authorized
borrowing limit of course uh and uh to
thank the audit committee and the
audit and government corporate
governance scrutiny committee considered
the you know they've they've considered
this three to RE Management reports and
asked us uh as darling close to report
into uh a number of factors one of which
is uh as of course our
um a look at our ethical Investments
which I absolutely endorse we should
look out
and so other than that chair uh I'd like
to move the recommendations uh 6.1 to
6.4
uh unless there's any other questions
can I have a seconder
very happy to Second yet thank you
councilor Dale
are there any comments
councilor Shipman
thanks Jay yeah I'm glad that the
amendment that was made in that
committee has ended up in the tragedy
about the ethical Investments I think
it's important that we show a bit of
leadership on where we're putting
taxpayers money
um and it's not doing something that's
obviously
counterproductive to the uh council's
climate um emergency goals so I'm
pleased to see it it's made it here and
um I'm glad that uh councilor parking
support and I'd also like to thank the
committee actually I think well it will
supported unanimously like committed
from everybody from all councils of all
followers on there so yeah well done
thank you
any other speaker
Council they are the Jewish to speak
that now I'm fine Chad just happy to uh
move to the vote
thank you
go to the boat thank you chair as this
is part of the budget we will be doing
recorded for a vote so I'll be reading
out your names in turn for you to give
me your vote starting with counselor
Wright
foreignly
Council windley
four
councilor Whitehead
or
Council Welton
Council Thacker
that's a Tate
oh
that's a stone
well that's a man
or that's a rough poor that's a row
or Council Ridgeway
four Council Renwick for that's a reader
four that's the power
out support
that's the Pickering or Council parking
oh
Council Lily
well
that's a little bit or
answer Lewis or
that's a Kerry
that was a Kenyan or Pastor Jones four
that's a Hutchinson Hutchinson
Castle thank you councilor Hill oh
that's a hard time well that's a Hancock
oh
Council Hall
countless counselor Gomez really
or Council fernel
four Council Mark Foster four cancer
four that's the Emmons four Council
Elliott four
Council Dayton four answer Dale or
Council Cupid four Council Cornwall
four that's a Cooper
four that's a class
oh councilor Pat bone
four that's the K bone
four Council Birkin
four Council Barker
or cancer Armitage four
four
as unanimous encourage and carrot thank
you
foreign
the first question is from councilor
Shipman direct to the deputy leader and
portfolio holder for Environmental
Services councilor Cupid
question about councilor Shipman
yeah thank you chair um there's a
significant number of residents that
have been in touch with me uh regarding
the collection and treatment of our
recycling waste
um I think last year there was actually
some national news on this actually
because I think
we were landfilling some of our
recycling uh for a short while while the
uh I think might have been stuffing
issues at supplier
um so I was just doing a bit of casework
actually which led me to this because I
was looking at what we actually do with
um recycling once we get rid of it to
somewhere where it's supposed to be
going
um and I was struggling to find
what they are what the outputs of these
people that we are sending our ways to
do with it so I was just wondering what
um
what um
what do we do to monitor the performance
of our contractors and what they
actually do with our waste are we
actually monitoring that at all or are
we simply Contracting them giving them a
waste and then we're going well it's
going through a recycling after that
point we don't care about it so I just
wanted to know what we're doing to
monitor it
Council kill pet
thank you chair
um thank you to councilor Shipman for
his question
um I'd be interested to know what you
mean by a significant number of
residents because I can't say this is
something I've received a lot of contact
about and I think generally we've got a
really positive and high standard of
waste and recycling collection from
feedback from residents uh so I'm
grateful to obviously are our collectors
and contractors for that
um nevertheless if you're referring to
things as you say such as recent
Guardian article on the export of
plastic waste and uh recent media
exposes over recent uh years which
attract recycling I'm sure you'll Echo
me in supporting the government's
current environment Bill progressing
through Parliament and the recycling
Minister's commitment to go further than
the eu's new regulations by Banning the
export of all categories of plastic
waste it's a non-oecd countries which I
think is one of the issues you're
referring to including tougher controls
on waste exports and mandatory
electronic waste tracking in terms of
what you just specifically asked about
our Council you may be aware that our
curbside recycling collections are
carried out by a contractor but I can
confirm that the council monitor this
closely and as part of that we require
both monthly and quarterly reports from
them which we have to submit to both
Darwish County Council as the relevant
Waste Authority and also so we get the
relevant recycling credits but it's also
submitted to defra for the reasons I've
just outlined above who have a tight
it's called a waste data flow system
which monitors waste and recycling from
sort of cradle to grave I think is the
term from the point of collection right
up to the end company or material result
um I don't know if counselorshipman's
seen the waste data flow system but if
you have looked at it you can see that
different items of recycling go to a
variety of different specialized
companies once they're collected at the
curbside I hope that helps
yeah I mean that's that's great actually
in fact I think
all of your commit to actually
publishing this data for people so I
think you know there's climate groups in
Northeast Harvest that I'd love to be
able to look at this data I don't know
if you've got a link to it and that we
can put out
um but because that's that's the sort of
data that I was trying to get hold of
actually and it didn't seem like the
council had it so I don't know if you
could kind of show me where that'll be
and I couldn't afford it
been in books let me great
thanks oh sorry chair am I okay to come
back in
yes you can cancel thanks chair uh
thanks councilor Shipman I can confirm
that uh even before this question
councilor Powell uh and I as
Communications portfolio holder and also
councilor Kenyan from his climate change
perspective I've been discussing this uh
because it is really important and it's
actually just a form of Interest as you
say to know when you put the plastic
bottle in the bin where does it go where
does it end up uh so yeah we've been
discussing a wider comms campaign on
this
um in both in the NAD news and also
online with a sort of cartoon strip or
videos and things like that
um and your exact question answer
shipment about where each individual
company goes to is actually there's
actually quite a big piece on the
Derbyshire County Council website which
is linked to on the northeast Derbyshire
website now uh with an interactive what
happens to my Recycling and you can
click on each individual item and then
it shows you where the company is it
goes to is eventually and what it's made
into so you know yogurt pots going to
pellets and things like that so I hope
that helps and I can confirm we'll be
carrying on to do that sort of comms
because I think it is important
thank you
the second question is from councilor
Hancock director to the deputy leader
and portfolio holder for Environmental
Services councilor Cooper
councilor Hancock thank you chair and
again just for for Charlotte's benefit
here it is a case of of making sure
there's a public awareness in getting
the message out there because we know
things happen but people don't always
get the um get the thing and one of the
same conversation it's very much
anecdotal stuff and it's what's said to
us and one of the key things is oh I
can't be bothered to recycle because I
do this I have to do that I have to do
the other and and people pick up on
these things and as we know we've got
people like we had a member of the
public earlier who very very proactive
very much wanting to do the right thing
and then we have other people who
it becomes an effort and every obstacle
that that's there so so one of the
things that is raised surprisingly
regularly actually when you talk to
people is why do we have to segregate
these things here when they all go into
the same receptacle
and I know I've seen and and admittedly
it is somewhat out of date information
now from other councils that actually
the better recycling
targets come from people who don't
actually have to sort anything where
it's all done at the end and you just
have one bin but I'm I'm not sure that
that's necessarily the right way forward
but it's it's a case of of looking and
encouraging recycling by actually not
placing obstacles in the way of uh of
people who want to so it's it's asking
for for an answer really as to do we
need to carry on doing it because we can
actually probably encourage more
recycling if we got rid of it
thank you and further comments that
counts the cupid
thank you chair and again thanks to
councilor Hancock for his question uh I
think some of it is is or some of my
answer is slightly covered by uh what I
just said about comms and that's
something we're trying to be really
proactive on
um I think as you say recycling is
important to every one of us in this
chamber both from reducing waste which
on its own is really important but then
also from climate change uh perspectives
as well
um so yeah I think it's in terms of I
know your question refers to sorting
recycling as meaningless but I think
that's obviously quite a disappointing
phrase to use because items placed
separately as advised in the the sort of
calendars are kept separately unless
it's for a specific reason so for
instance paper because we separate it it
increases its grading and maintains its
quality so it goes into a different
stream
um I do I take you points about making
it as easy as possible for residents and
I think on the whole we do do that in
Northeast Ireland sure because we do
have just the two compartments and then
obviously the three bins whereas I've
known some areas in the country have
five or six different boxes and colored
bins and it does start to get very
confusing
um so I think overall the ease of
recycling in our district is reflected
by current Ned recycling rates and
overall low contamination rates as well
which is also really key with recycling
um the most recent recycling tables put
us in the top third of the country and
the top 25 of local authorities on
recycling things such as plastic glass
cans and one of the highest in the
Midlands at an overall rate of I think
it's 47.2 percent
but I know that we need to do more I'm
really grateful to residents for the
time to they take to rinse and sort
their Recycling and I hope everyone will
continue to do that but as I say we're
going to try and keep driving recycling
rates up and I know that's something
that counselor Kenyan often asks me as
well and I think one of the key things
to enable us to do this going forwards
to really drive up our rate with other
other councils is both the national
legislative changes that are coming in
um but also encouraging more residents
to compost or separate their food waste
into their green bins so I hope you'll
also sort of join me in doing that and
really pushing that aspect of it too
thanks Jeff thank you councilor and
Clark do you have a supplementary
question you'd like to ask
uh yes yes thank you chair uh purely
Beyond asking um asking uh councilor
Cupid and it's not not one to answer now
but to actually push the communications
because the public perception that the
word meaningless wasn't mine that's the
word that's being used by multiple
people and that's how they're perceiving
it so if I can ask that we actually
improve our Communications on that
aspect too that would be would be most
helpful
thank you Chad thank you
comes the cupid
uh yeah just to confirm uh chair I think
that's similar to the answer that I gave
councilor Shipman will continue uh
working on this as I say councilor
Powell and I had already been coming up
with um a bit of a strategy
um we were hoping to also do a film but
for obvious reasons you can't do that in
the waste and recycling industry at the
moment due to covid but we will do that
as soon as possible
um and we're trying to also do a sort of
FAQs on
strange things that you're not sure
whether you can recycle and also showing
you why it is really important to
separate out you're in their caddy and
to stop it getting contaminated so your
paper Etc thank you chair
foreign
that concluded today's questions we will
now move to the next item on our agendas
thank you
item 10 to consider any motions from
members and the procedure rule 10. I can
confirm that we have received two
motions for today's meeting
can I invite councilor shipment to Move
Motion a on today's agenda yeah thank
you chair
um
can I
ask you if you could speak up that
little bit louder I'm unable to hear you
thank you sorry is that any better
yeah
okay yeah so so
um I've had residents come to me talking
to me about how they love walking they
participated in the uh Beat the Street
um in um
but one thing that keeps cropping up
especially the elderly residents is
ensuring that there's adequate seating
along popular walking routes because I
think more people would walk especially
the elderly ones or people who travel to
to walk and need a rest every now and
then I think they would be more
encouraged to go out if they actually if
we could look at popular walking route
so make sure there is seating available
um there's not much more to say than
that it's not very complicated motion
it's quite you know it's it
but I think we do need to look at this
because I think especially with with
people being involved more and we're
trying to get them out to exercise I
think it's something that would have
seriously helped those trouble to walk
in this District
thank you chair
can I have a second of players
I'll second that reserve the right to
speak if I need to later please
thank you
other speakers
checks
a chair um I'm sloganian thank you
uh yes I completely agree with the
sentiments of the motion I'm very aware
of the positive impact of local walking
and uh I fought past and scenery and so
on uh have um from being a member of
Ramblers for a lot of years and one of
the few good things from K we've just
been to see people uh rediscovering
local walking they also agree we have a
responsibility to make it accessible
as a district council we already provide
a lot of benches on our own property
because mainly it's in the Parks and
things like that and it's already
business as usual for us to provide them
in those sorts of locations
but but this council is not responsible
for the vast majority of popular walking
routes through the district we don't own
the relevant land and it's nearly all
highways or private land
um
and footpaths are generally the
responsibility of the County Council
um and for the last six months I've been
talking with active Derbyshire that's
the county Organization for this sort of
thing about our local walking routes
because we need to invest the need to
invest in our interest walking
infrastructure and tell residents about
it
so our group will not be supporting this
motion and I suggest the appropriate
place to raise this is with the County
Council which is what we're already
doing as an Administration
thank you
Council Shipman do you wish to exercise
your right of reply
I think councilor Barker wants to talk
chair I'm sorry councilor Parker
that's it it's gone thank you chair yeah
just before Ross comes back
again the sentiments are fine and uh the
more people that you're out walking the
better and enjoying Trails but
same same mind it's not really a
district council function and I know a
lot of parish council at Wingfield it's
one of the things that we
we do agonize where to put these benches
to be honest it's never it's never a
simple thing you'd think that were an
easy job to find somewhere to put a
bench but uh We've ended up falling out
with folks because nobody wants it in
front of their house but there you go uh
so uh we won't be supporting each other
uh Ross uh we fully accept your premise
you know about getting people active and
that but we don't believe that
Parish Council best best councils
because they know where where to put
benches out of thought in their local
communities like the top you know where
where people need them most it could
back diamonds if we put one somewhere
the district council it could be in
wrong place so they so we won't be
supporting each other
thank you come
thank you Council Hall I'm sorry uh just
just to quickly touch upon something I
like to go out walking I like to go out
running and I do have to say that I'm
not one of the counselors or sorry not a
counselor not one of the people that
drive me car to uh places to actually go
for a walk so normally it involves
walking on roads and things like that
locally before I get to the countryside
and one of the things again probably not
our responsibility one of the biggest
bug bars and this comes from members of
public is parking on footpaths and now
it has an eddc it's not our
responsibility and I know there was a
public consultation last year regarding
it why is it that London prohibits uh
parking on foot paths but the rest of
the country doesn't now that's
discriminatory as well against disabled
and elderly people because it's okay for
elderly people to walk on boat paths in
London or disabled people but it's not
for us and I think as that not just our
Council as other councils and the police
it's something that needs to be
addressed really with immediate effect
and not in a year or five years or
anything like that sorry I just thought
I'd let make my point thank you
thank you Council reader
yeah Ross unfortunately I'm in the
position of not being able to support it
either just because
um I just want to Champion everything
that the parish councils do in in terms
of my uh parish council at Clay Cross
we've got a fantastic group in the
kenning Park group who have have placed
benches around that Park the parish
council does lots and lots of work very
locally on the ground knowing the area
really really well and I know that if
there's any support that we need from
the district council you know the
channels are open there to to have
conversations from that that Parish
level
um if if we need support with it and
we've heard earlier about and beat the
street that happened in Clay Cross and
and I think lots of people of varying
ages took part in that which was amazing
um you know so it's not that I don't
support that you know that we should
have more resting places and things like
that I just think perhaps this is not
the correct forum for this conversation
I think Parish councils are probably
best to be having those conversations
and looking more locally at the areas
thank you
councilor Chapman
oh sorry councilor Foster mark
uh thank you chair uh yeah I support the
comments of councilor reader and
councilor Barker uh I believe it is a
it's a parish and town level
um I know that because it's something
we've done a lot of in dronfield we've
supported uh many benches
um so it's something we've done a lot of
um and it's interesting to know it's
being done in other areas perhaps uh I
know it's not a question for here but
perhaps uh councilor Shipman could come
back and tell us what he's done in
Topton if he's fitted any Adventures
himself he might have I know we've done
an awful lot it'd be interesting to know
what he has done
I don't know the answer by the way
counselor and Clark
thank you chair and first of all as soon
as I've been friends with Ross for years
you're the very first person I've ever
known telling him to speak up
I I support holy-heartedly what
councilor Hall has said because I that's
one of my huge book bears as well
um in response to council's Barker
reader and Foster
I totally get where they're coming from
and in top 10 we have fitted benches and
various other things I think what
counselors are perhaps
I won't say use the word ignoring but
there's a difference between those of us
those Parish councils which have a
relatively large budget and some
parishes have a very small budget
so at Parish level all things aren't
equal and what larger parishes like
Topton North Wingfield and certainly
dronfield can do not every Parish has
that capacity and ultimately as as a
body we're responsible for health and
well-being so I think there is an
element of us taking accountability here
so I think that this is the spirit of
the motion this is the purpose of it
we're here to look after everyone and
that's uh that's the the key behind it
so I fully support it
councilor Shipman
thank you chair
um
obviously agreeing with the sentiments
of emotion doesn't really get any action
so although you might agree with the
sentiments it doesn't actually achieve
anything for people in Northeast Africa
definitely except that Parish councils
will pay for ventures get somebody
contracted them to come and fit it but
the real problem is that there's no
joint of thinking throughout the
district so you end up with piecemeal
solutions to a problem
people will walk in between let's say
tucked and pay crafts there's no use of
putting a bench on Queen Victoria Road
if people aren't traveling from there to
get to play across just you know what I
mean you're going to put them along the
routes that people use it's the district
council who will work as it's as it has
been said earlier with the County
Council to find those places those
walking routes the district council
we're working with Council on various
schemes and probably the streets one of
them where where it's bringing the
authorities together to make sure that
these things are installed and in the
right ways I don't think these meal
Solutions just in different parishes is
what's required we want people traveling
between our villagers to increase to
boost the economy to get people you know
meeting each other new people and all
that kind of thing I think we need to
actually look at a bigger kind of review
of it all make sure we can join these
places up and I'm finished I didn't
realize as many people would want to
talk about benches as they have
um so yeah I'm glad that it's it's an
issue that other people have noticed as
well but I wouldn't like to see us
actually pushing this because it is
stuff that residency in my ward have
brought up
um so I think we need to actually look
at what we can do across the district
thank you
we'll now move to the boat
at knicker
yeah the the poll is in progress
currently excuse me chair I did put my
hand up to speak before I'm so sorry
sorry
yeah
um I just wanted to say that I think in
this time
I think that you know
sentiments aside I think we have to be
careful if we go ahead with this one
because we've heard in the press that
you know we're not allowed to sit down
on benches that we get told off and
things like that and I think this is
something that maybe should be put on
the back burner and brought up when the
covered restrictions for people going
out walking meeting up with other people
sitting down on benches having a drink
being told off by the police that they
can't do that I think you know I think
rather than sort of going for the vote
and and saying they or yay I think
really this should be deferred and maybe
brought back to this full council at
another time when we can actually sit
and be honest honest about it because as
it is right now we're voting against
something that may be very important in
another year or two years time
is anyone else
uh chat
sorry uh are we talking about whether
we're going to have the vote or not or
yes we're going to move to the vote okay
thank you
foreign
against or abstain
a vaulted once can I vote again
please because I canceled it off when
the pants originally which wanted to
speak that's fine are we should pull
back with me one moment
you should have a new poll in front of
you everyone can vote again
just another two members to vote
good luck
okay I'll end the polling there
and I'll share the results
um in the chamber Nikki there's two
against
so two against which makes the the vote
four against thirteen sorry four four
thirty nine against two absentions
the motion Falls chair
motions defeated
can I now move to uh the exclusion of
public I'm sorry
I do beg your pardon
Council Ann Clark
do this
thank you chair
um I'll I'll speed this up as quickly as
possible so that the chair can move to
exclusion
the uh the key of this and I'm not going
to sit here and be a hypocrite I'm not
looking at Council spending more money
when I'm already opposing what we're
doing in kilimage the key thing is we
need to be aware of balance we have got
increasing population in the South the
vast majority of the building that we
have got is in the south of the district
we're throwing the investment into the
North
we need to have a review and that is
that is the key thing here is have a
review of where these where we've
actually got this provision to make sure
that it's in proportion with the
population that we've got in the
district and then look towards address
so it is a long-term plan it's not a
quick win one something like this can't
be
um and that's that's the uh the logic
behind it is is a review of what we've
got where we've got it because we
haven't got it where our population is
increasing
second day
[Music]
sorry I'll second that whoops
thank you
any speakers
comes Kenyan
thank you
um yes uh this Council has an indoor
sport facility strategy it runs from
2017 to 2033 it was created by
independent experts in sport England uh
analyzing the provision of support
facilities within the district
the strategy is Council blind and
Boundary blind and it looks at things
from the resident's new point which is
ultimately what matters which also
recognizes that Leisure centers vary in
size and facilities and in the north the
facility the
um different types of facilities like
swimming badminton courts what have you
they're spread across smaller facilities
than in the smaller Leisure centers in
the South and so this report looks at
the ranger facilities and their
distribution and so on the strategy was
commissioned by the the previous labor
Administration actually but clearly it
did leave them with a problem as it
required spending on upgrading or
replacing some of the facilities and it
was known at the time that there were
issues with the air provision in the
North in particular the kilimash sports
center provision I I have a lot of
sympathy with the situation they found
themselves in and I also recognized that
the work that they undertook from that
report uh though of course funding is
always a problem that strategy States
Northeast Derbyshire Council needs to
consider how it will work with Partners
to ensure that the current stock of
facilities remains open and accessible
to the General Public
our proposals for Charlie Park in the
South will result in easily our largest
most modern facility and provide high
quality accessible Leisure Services to
the vast majority of residents in the
south of the district and that has been
considerably helped by the government's
Town deal funding program
the report also says about specifically
about the killer Marsh Center the
primary issue is ensuring its ongoing
availability to the general public at
the requisite level of quality and
maintaining the quality and variety of
the program of activities provided
and there's councilor Barker explained
that our last Council the previous
administration couldn't find a way to
action this concern and they had to
shelve it though as I say I have
sympathy with the position they found
themselves in however by working with
kilmarsh Parish Council we've found a
way forwards as this Council discussed
and agreed at length last month that
decision is about being fair with our
residents and not taking it on will be
the equivalent of asking say top 10
residents to pay twice for their roads
or North Wingfield residents to pay
twice for their bins being emptied just
to balance our budget
so it's also worth noting that the
impact on the budget as we were talking
about earlier the budget earlier is
quite small even compared to just the
cost of our other Leisure centers if the
killer Marsh provision was a concern it
would pale when compared to some of the
other uh Leisure Center costs
um so to answer the motion the evidence
does not support the claim of a
disparity of leisure service provision
between North and South the council has
already done the review requested it's
now working proactively to maintain the
current balance provision that we have
and to address the identified quality
shortcomings and financial imbalance so
our group will not be supporting this
motion as it's already actionable
foreign
[Music]
thank you chair and and yes right Jeremy
yeah you're right we uh we did set all
that emotion and uh
again we've got this Motion in front of
us and I don't know whether it to
revisit the killer Marsh decision or
whatever but uh we'll not do that uh I
think as a district as a small District
uh we've always proud of ourselves you
know to have the the Leisure facilities
that we've had in a district like ours
uh dronfield Charlie Park neckington
we've done really well and and it has
cost money in the past and I think we
had just we just about turned that round
and hopefully when when we get Charlie
part the new thing that'll be uh
Paul's yarning right and everything will
will uh that'll be even better because
it does need to go to looking at you
Alice but there's no two ways about it
uh it's been there a long while and it
does need a new facility in the uh in
the south of the district so uh we won't
be supporting this I think we've done
well where we are uh and and I for one
don't want a Leisure Center in North
Wingfield whether you want whether or
not and I know there's I don't want that
rammy neck I'm going off on as they say
so uh Charlie Park is is a if we can get
it modernized and up to the standard
that we'd like it's a marvelous facility
uh for the south of the district
and again just just we really do hope
that the kilimash initiative pays off
and it's a well-run and and it links in
well with eckington swimming pool and
everything comes out rolls their book uh
I think there's some big gifts in all
that so and and I'm sure dronfield's
doing doing quite well at the moment
which is great uh and I think and and
let's not forget I mean it's not
something we want to plug but there are
private facilities out there as well
that that you get that folks can they
can use for gyms and uh and those sorts
of facilities so I don't think we we
should have uh facilities particularly
in Northeast Derbyshire and and the
longer we can keep them publicly run
and funded the better and uh let's see
let's see what happens so again sorry
David and Ross and bum that we won't be
uh supporting that to that but I think
it's all been done it's the next Daniel
exercise that somebody's looking he's
part of the local plan as well if
it's only a chapter within the local
plan but we'll not open that one now
Charlotte shall we
thank you
councilor shipment
I just want to say
that this this
um review that you you're talking about
are your own admissions was done four
years ago
about four years ago that's prior to
covid prior to we've got brexit on New
Horizons prior to transport links
disappearing that's prior to all these
other things that have happened since
you can't be relying on a report from
four years ago in any business or
organization
and try and argue that that's legit
evidence you're just not going to get
away with that what what this is calling
for is to look to see if there's an
imbalance if there's no imbalance as you
seem to be so confident about then why
not let's do the review and see if
there's an imbalance so I've got
residents that I'm supposed to be
represented make sure that they've got
the facilities and and stuff that can go
at the services they can go and use I'm
not here to tell them that there's no
imbalance because of some report four
years ago we need to be doing it and
keeping it up to date that's the whole
point we're gonna bury it in the sand
and that's not proactive that's actually
waiting for things to happen because in
10 years time you'll be going oh well we
needed a new Leisure Center down itself
because another 7 000 houses have been
built that's not very that's you know
residents are not going to have that
they're not going to accept that that's
why we need to make sure periodically
we're reviewing to see if there's any
imbalances in luxury facilities
thank you Council of Foster
uh thank you chair uh first I'd like to
address the councilor Barker uh yes I
think John Field uh Center has been
doing well and I think a lot of that's
down to the work of the last
Administration to
um I think at the last count is making
something like a 90 000 Surplus so so
yeah I'm quite pleased with it and I use
it and I think I think a good job was
done on that uh when it comes to this
motion uh when we're looking at this
review so Council resolves to review
this seems to be something that the Dems
don't seem to understand it's clear to
conservatives and it's clear to labor
counselors here that when you want to
review you do it through a scrutiny
committee we've had this time and time
again and it's costing a lot of time at
Council all you have to do is take it to
the relevant scrutiny committee discuss
it there spend the time discussing it
there when you look at the previous
reviews that have been done into Leisure
provision they've been commissioned at
scrutiny committees that's where it
should be took and that's what I'd
recommend and I think you're going to
continue doing this we seems to
understand this apart from uh the lib
Dems so it puzzles me uh maybe we can
get a note sent out to you give me some
instruction on this but yeah he said
scrutiny committee
uh if it's a Leisure Center you're
looking for in Topton I don't think it's
going to happen you know maybe you
should look at putting a couple apart
benches from your Parish Council
thank you councilor reader and then
councilor Dale
Mr I think a scrutiny review and topic
such as this if you've got concerns
about Leisure provision across the the
district would be a more appropriate
Forum to take it to and and Council
Foster took the words right out of my
mouth with that you know it it would
definitely be a better place really to
have those discussions but in terms of
clay crafts you know we were working
really hard through the last
Administration to try and get that
facility up to and I'm sure our
residents would prefer to have a really
good quality provision
that that meets the needs of those
people rather than just trying to plunk
one everywhere do you know what I mean
so I think it is better to have a re you
know a scrutiny review look at it rather
than wasting time in council with this
subject and and really get to grips of
what concerns you've got and I don't
think any counselor sat around this
table across whatever party you're in
would dispute that Leisure Services are
important and we need them in the
district but it's about you know quality
for me and getting the quality there
North Wing feels very close to us we we
you know we want people to come into
Clay Cross and to do that we need a
quality provision so I'm hoping that the
Town Center bid that's going in at the
moment will form part of boost in that
that economy around the Leisure Center
so I think there's more appropriate ways
to look at it
thank you Council Dale
um just I just want to address councilor
Shipman's Point
um he referred to uh it being a bit of a
short-term review but my understanding
is councilor Kenyon and councilor Barker
have already alluded to it was a
long-term review that looked forward to
2033 or 2034 or and as I understand it
as councilor Barker said it was it was
baked into the local plan as well and
obviously the local plan reflects the uh
you know the level of development within
that area so I think that that point to
be honest is largely covered off by by
those factors I just want to Echo as
well what councilor Barker and what
councilor Kenyan have said I think that
we have the balance right and even
better so
um with with kilimash ensuring the
long-term sustainability of the killer
Marsh facility and the uh the project
that we're working on there with the
parish council
um we're ambitious for leisure though as
an Administration and actually this
isn't about
um kind of uh one or the other it's not
a case of killer Marsh or Charlie Park
we're ambitious for all of our Ledger
facilities and I'm disappointed that the
way that this motion almost is coming
across is though you know I can tell
that the lib denim councilors are not
happy about the killer Marsh decision
but it feels a little bit like it's it's
presented as though uh it's it's one or
the other well it clearly isn't and as
an Administration we've been very
ambitious with with Charlie Parker as
well as Clay Cross and eckington for
that matter uh dronfield's had some
recent
um significant investment and and we are
putting uh more investment into
eckington there is a plan for killer
Marsh and obviously through the town
deal there is a very significant plan
for for Charlie Park so I think it's not
a case of one or the other we can we can
support all of our Leisure facilities uh
around the the district and the only
other final thing I would add is uh it's
a point the councilor reader made it
we've got to think about the viability
of these facilities as well if you have
one in every single Village you'll have
lots of unsuccessful uh Leisure centers
you won't have lots of successful ones
that's that's pure reality you need them
to be in the center of population bases
and I think that the locations that we
have them at the moment are best fit uh
for the district I appreciate some some
residents will have to travel that's
that's accepted but you've got to think
about the viability in the marketplace
that surround them and the local
populations and I think that they are in
the right place and as I say
um there is an investment plan and a
plan for improving them over the course
of the coming years so thank you chair
that's all I'd like to say
thank you councilor hall and then we'll
have counselor Oscar Gomez Regina
well thank you Chad yeah uh what um
councilor Barker and councilor Dale have
just mentioned councilor Parker
mentioned about this private gyms out
there as well and uh councilor Dale has
mentioned about viability if there's too
many too close to each other what hasn't
been mentioned it's not ours but it is a
very modern sport center in between Clay
Cross and Dron build and that's Queen's
Park Sports Center at Chesterfield I
know it's not ours but it's open to all
there's a swimming pool there and other
facilities So like
um uh councilor Dale says the viability
it would it be worth us putting one at
Haslam that's just a mile or so from
another Council Sports Central ready uh
I think one of the most important things
for us is a council all is encouraging
the use of this Sports Center as well
and it is proven like drum Field Sports
Center 16 refurbished it encourages more
people to use it so as they're saying is
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't force it to drink we can put
sports centers there we can't force them
people to use them it would be good to
see encouraged use of them though as
well
uh thank you
thank you counselor Gomez
thank you chair
um not really sure why this motion's
being brought forward by the lib Dems
they've voted no to the killer Marsh
Leisure Center but then they seem to be
one in a lot of small Leisure centers
across the district so I don't really
understand what the aim and motive is
there surely it's best that we actually
nurture the Leisure centers that we've
got as mentioned as a council we are
actually you know we're very pro-ar
Leisure centers very Pro Health
um so the only thing that I can think is
that the lib Dems are just trying to get
a bit of free at a time thank you
thank you
councilor Hancock do you wish to
exercise your right of reply yes chair
thank you
um in regards to uh to the issue of
scrutiny and uh I'll take particular
issue with councilor Foster given that
he's been one of the biggest critics of
scrutiny when he's not got his own way
through things going through there
um to respond to uh to councilor reader
the um this facility at uh Clay Cross is
brilliant and no one will want to do it
down at all it's a fantastic facility
um I actually agree with Alex in in what
he said it isn't a case of one or
another it's not picking it's it's
making the best of what we can
and I think the the key Point really
which is the whole point behind this
notion is is what councilor Gomez really
has just said it is about accessibility
um what we have and and I mean I I speak
here to a whole load of counselors
primarily who drive
if you don't drive even from Topton
which is the next Village on from Clay
Cross Clay Cross Leisure Center is not
that easy to get to
we're we are actually cutting it down I
mean the parking facility isn't huge
either for people who've got to drive
but it it's not so this is why
sometimes looking at multiple options
and smaller options I mean up in the
north we have got these three fairly
well staggered fairly accessible and and
I found it quite interesting councilor
Hall's bit when he's going on about
Queen's part when you've got ponds
forges over the board from border from
eckington and kilimarsh
um but that's that's me being sarcastic
um it is a case of making these things
accessible I mean councilor Kenyon was
using the word over and over again but
the reality is it's not it is
it is for some people if you're in North
Wingfield it is
in other places in other parts I mean
we've got Ash over we've got wingerworth
who are actually it's not an easy place
to get to if you don't drive and uh and
so we need to be looking at provision
and that's the thing and I mean in terms
of the review I mean Council Barker made
me laugh with the local plan issue let's
be honest do we really want to bring
that in because it's turned into the
biggest fastest councils had in decades
hasn't it and and the key thing with any
review
as I think we've said before in the last
Council it's about continuous
Improvement these reviews should be
rolling it shouldn't be a case of let's
look at this let's determine I think
this was a point councilor shimlan's
trying to get across it's no good
setting this for 20 years time because
things change in that things have
changed in the last 12 months beyond
recognition and any review has to be
robust enough to actually say right well
we've planned this but actually now
things have changed we need to revisit
it we need to re-look at it so it's
accepting that reality so it's not sour
grapes against killer Marsh I actually
started saying I'm not going to Advocate
spending more on on that when I've
already opposed this it's actually
saying let's review it let's make sure
that we've got is actually accessible to
all of our residents and fit for purpose
and right now what we have once it looks
good on paper they're fantastic
facilities but in terms of actually
serving all of our all of our districts
it doesn't
and that's the purpose behind this
motion
thank you we'll now move to the vote
sure yeah also
point of order
sorry if I can give a personal
explanation I believe you that's under a
point of order if you remember from uh
Council on
could I speak chair yes thank you uh
I've never been a Critic of scrutiny
always been a big fan of scrutiny I
think it works uh it worked well when I
was in opposition when I worked with a
counselor reader in communities we all
work very well together we work very
well as a team and perhaps that's what
I'd encourage the lib Dems to do work as
a team in communities and the rest of
the scrutiny
thank you
thank you we'll now move to the boat
thank you okay
thank you chair I'm just launching the
poll now
remember you should see that on your
screens if you would be kind enough to
vote for against or abstain
[Music]
I make that all votes have been received
and I will just share the results on
your screen I have indication that the
recording has stopped
apologies for them announcement um
they're
are two votes against in the chamber
and 39 votes against online which means
that's carried sorry not carried that it
the motion Falls chair
thank you
item 11. explosion of public
I will now move that the public be
excluded from the meeting I move that
the public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
item of business to avoid the disclosure
to them of exempt information as defined
in paragraphs one and two part one of
schedule 12a of the global Government
Act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
they are the seconder our second chair
we will now vote by Paul
Nikki
chair that Paul has been launched
waiting for the votes to come in
[Music]
just waiting for one more vote to arrive
online
that's all
um all votes in I'll just share that
with two votes four from the chamber
that would be 42 for um and the motion
is carried
thank you
chair we will just now prepare to stop
the live feed